[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gilt ein absolutes wunschkind
ich glaube die meisten von euch haben
schon mal geschrieben sally bitte mach
doch mal donuts heute ist es endlich
soweit ich erzähle euch und murat den
hund und mache heute selbst gemachte
donuts dann für das ich so ein bisschen
wie homer simpson kann sich dann
hinsetzen mit seinem rosa donath und
kann auf der baustelle noch alle
handwerker damit versorgen
donuts bestehen immer aus einem hefeteig
und ich mache heute die klassische
variante nämlich frittierte donuts ihr
könnt natürlich auch welche aus dem
backofen machen aber ich finde backofen
download ist sich doch er sah aus wie
buchteln weil es eben nicht er also
nicht mit fett gebacken wird daher heute
ganz klassisch und ich stelle jetzt
erstmal den hefeteig habt für den
hefeteig verwende ich einen würfel hefe
zwei esslöffel warmes wasser 50 gramm
zucker 800 bis 850 gramm mehl 2 eier und
2 eigelbe 3 150 milliliter milch einen
teelöffel salz etwas vanille extrakt 70
gramm butter und eine unbehandelte
zitrone
zuerst machen jetzt einen vorteig das
heißt ich nehme jetzt die hefe und
brösel sich hier ins warme wasser das
bewegt auch dass der teig später ein
bisschen schneller aufgeht
so könnte auch immer schon die hefe
kontrollieren wenn sie nämlich gleich
schön aufgeht dann wisst ihr okay meine
hilfe ist gut und dann kann ich sie eben
weiter verarbeiten so ein bisschen
verrühren zucker jetzt denke ich du hier
für mich schon mal ab und können der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal meine truppe
ein bisschen erwärmen und die milch
erwärmen dass die schönen lauwarm ist
und das sag ich jetzt so ungefähr fünf
bis sieben minuten stehen bis es so
kleine blume bläschen bildet
[Musik]
nämlich die hefe dies ist aufgegangen
und die kommt jetzt hier in die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig
natürlich auch mit der hand verkneten
das soll jetzt die restlichen zutaten
und ich nehme jetzt erst immer einen
teil des öls und führte dann immer
langsam den rest dazu waren wir milch
eier und eigelb das macht den teig
richtig schön saftig und locker für den
extra geschmack natürlich man den
extrakt
ich habe es mal ohne gemacht und da hat
es echt gewählt am geschmack ein
bisschen zitronenschale nicht so viel
wiegt nur so eine prise dann den
restlichen zucker das salz und jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen verrühren und dann
gebe ich nach und nach noch die butter
dazu und das restliche mehl und beim
mehl kann sein dass ihr das komplette
mail benutzt also 850 gramm körper auch
sein dass sie nur 820 braucht da gucke
ich dann gleich und fiel einfach mal
[Musik]
nun steht es nach und nach das mehl dazu
und dann las ich den teig erstmal so
fünf bis sieben minuten lang nähten
und wenn er dann noch ein bisschen klebt
gebe ich noch das restliche mehl dazu
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig gut ich habe es bei
mir das komplette mehl verwendet
ich hätte nämlich etwas große feier
gerade als ausgemacht ob jetzt hört sich
komisch an aber es ist so jetzt den teig
ein bisschen durch kneten oder zumindest
halt so zu einer kugel formen
ich sehe das auch einfach schön
geschmeidig trotzdem schön weich und das
ist eben auch ganz wichtig dass er
einfach schön weich wird damit die donau
schön luftig werden jetzt einfach die
schüssel nehmen ein bisschen fetten mit
back transport zum beispiel dann den
teig reinlegen
christian buck trends bei obendrauf
abdecken und für ungefähr eine stunde
aufgehen lassen
der teig ist jetzt richtig schön
aufgegangen und jetzt wieder ausgerollt
das erst mal auf einer arbeitsplatte
geben möchten zum beispiel auf eine
silikon matte da braucht man nämlich
generell einfach weniger mehl dann klebt
jetzt müsst ihr noch gar nicht mehr so
arg bearbeiten oder kneten jetzt ein
bisschen mehl darunter ein bisschen mehr
drüber
jetzt ist wichtig dass der teig
gleichmäßig ausgerollt wird
ihr könnt jetzt zum beispiel auch mit
den hölzern arbeiten die ich immer oft
habe diese teig hölzer und können den
teig jetzt auf einem zentimeter stärke
ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig schön gleichmäßig
ausgerollt und jetzt nämlich ein rundes
ausstich förmchen taucht kurz in mehl so
bleibt es nicht leben
und jetzt kann ich hier die ringe
ausstechen jetzt nehme ich einen
kleineren ausstecher für das loch in der
mitte und stehe ich jetzt hier kleinen
kreise aus und dietrich dann meistens
eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr zusammen
kneten weil ich da einfach mini berlin
oder minijobs draus mache aber ihr könnt
die natürlich auch gerne nehmen und dann
noch mal zusammen kneten mit der übrigen
teig hier außenrum einfach wegnehmen
wieder zusammen kneten dass man so ein
bisschen abklopfen und dann las ich den
immer noch mal ganz kurz auf gehen damit
dass ich wieder entspannt wieder
ausrollen und dann wieder weiter zu
donuts verarbeiten
und jetzt kommt das geheimnis und zwar
nehmen wir jetzt diese donath teiglinge
und legt sie auf ein stück backpapier
und jetzt lasse ich sie ja gleich noch
mal raufgehen noch mal eine halbe stunde
dann werden sie schön locker und oftmals
ist es ja so wenn man dann die donuts in
die hand nimmt oder ins bett schmeißt
dann gehen sie eben zusammen weil man
einfach zu viel am tag rum macht
deswegen einfach diese backpapier stücke
zu schneiden
da kann ich sie darauf aufgehen lassen
und später einfach so ganz vorsichtig
ins bett liegen
unsere besten dann einfach direkt auf
dem blech legen abdecken und für
mindestens 30 minuten ruhen lassen wobei
hier verteilt ist aber ganz wichtig dass
in der küche kein fenster geöffnet ist
das kein luft so kommt und der hefeteig
nicht wieder zusammenfällt
ich weiß gar nichts mit button jetzt zu
tun auf ihrem zweiten album lasso stein
in anthrazit oder herrlich jetzt das
hause schon zu dunkel aber die
mauersteine sind hell
trotzdem hält okay da es geht um
pflasterstein ist ökopflaster da ich
jetzt schon ja oder nein ich habe alles
mit mir nie so perfekt drauf kommt oder
sowas und ölfleck oder irgendwas sind
die sieger aus doch dunkel
ich mag sein
okay das war schon günstiger ich kenne
mich dann hat aus aber okay
jetzt sind die donuts richtig schön
aufgegangen und jetzt kann ich hier ich
habe jetzt hier das fett in der friteuse
erhitzt ihr könnt natürlich auch einen
topf nehmen und wirklich die hitze
reduzieren also die hitze sollte so
einfach 150 maximum 160 grad seien nicht
so heiß sonst verbrennen sie aus und so
schnell bleiben werden natürlich richtig
dunkel und ihnen bleiben es einfach noch
wo jetzt habe ich hier meinen backpapier
und liegt jetzt ganz vorsichtig ins fett
ich zeige euch gleich noch eine methode
die etwas sicherer ist backpapier dann
rausziehen auf keinen fall ins feld
plumpsen lassen und spritzt euch nämlich
das heiße fett ins gesicht aber am
besten ist es sowieso moment ich hole
kurz was ihr nehmt zum beispiel einem
schaumlöffel liegt da hinein vorsichtig
rein gleiten lassen und dann mit einer
zange das backpapier herausnehmen und
jetzt von beiden seiten zu etwa zwei bis
maximal drei minuten auspacken und dann
am besten mit kochlöffeln zum beispiel
wenden oder mit zwei frühstücksmesser
das drückt man sie nämlich nicht wie mit
einer zange zum beispiel und dann
vorsichtig raus nehmen und auf
küchenpapier abtropfen lassen
ich mach jetzt einen teil der donuts mit
einer schokoladenglasur dafür nämlich
peter kuvertüre die habe ich bereits
gehackt und zwei drittel davon kommen
jetzt auch das warme wasser bord und
dann kann ich die schokolade schmelzen
und nehmen sie vom herd herunter und
wurde dann das restliche drittel ein
denn damals die perfekte verarbeitung
temperatur dann gibt es auch keinen
grauen schleier und die donuts glänzen
richtig schön so hieß jetzt die
kuvertüre schon geschmolzen
jetzt kommt das restliche drittel dazu
dann auch noch ein bisschen kokosfett
damit die kofferträger richtig schön
glänzt schoko version
ich werde am schönsten seen ja die rosen
aus mit der zuger klausur aber ich
glaube schoko schmeckt mir am besten wo
sie ausprobieren ich muss mal dann alle
drei probieren
damit kann ich ja erst nur wissen was
mir am besten schmeckt am besten nimmt
jetzt einen monat tauchten wieder
schönsten seite als er mit der schönen
runden seite in die kuvertüre und wenn
es schon perfekt ist musste nicht mal
mehr verstreichen sondern können es
einfach direkt hier auf den abzügen zu
setzen und entweder mit krokant oder zum
beispiel zucker straßen und strömen
hmm
august
ich weiß wir jetzt alles so gebannt vor
dem bildschirm sitzen ins handy beißen
wollen
probiert es echt aus dass ich wenn ihr
diese einfachen tipps beachtet dann
werden die echt super luftig und richtig
schön
ich sehe ja auch hier schon den
unterschied ich habe die schönen
luftigen donuts und hier habe ich die
etwas flacheren die habe ich einfach zu
wenig aufgehen lassen
ich wollte einfach und schnell
feierabend machen hat so schnell wie in
den gefrierschrank gesteckt und wenn man
die einfach länger aufgehen lässt werden
die frau so
ich kann mich nicht entscheiden ok ich
muss einen mit zimt zucker probieren
einen mit schokolade und krokant einen
mit schokolade und zucker und einen mit
zitronen foto zuckerguss und hier mache
ich jetzt noch zum zucker also zucker
und sind vermischen
die version hat sich der könig gewünscht
so kennt also nämlich aus früheren
zeiten genetik richards und downloads
und dann kann das sagen ob er so
schmeckt wie früher
ich nehme jetzt einen der nicht so heiß
ist okay aber heiß haft der zucker halt
besser dann gucken ob der donau ab dem
quinny test besteht dass man noch kurz
warten gleichwertig waren sorgt so 150
grad
ich glaube in rheinweiler vielleicht
heute noch ganz kurz in der minute
ich zeige schon mal in der zwischenzeit
vielleicht was ich noch gemacht habe und
zwar habe ich die teiglinge einfach
eingefroren
hier auf so einem torten retter dann
könnte nämlich weniger donuts macht
einfach alles schön vorbereiten
die habe ich jetzt nicht so lange
aufgehen lassen aber am besten nach der
aufgeht so einfrieren und wenn sie danke
frauen sind können dass er dann nämlich
schön verpacken luftdicht verschließen
und im gefrierfach lagern und dann
einfach gefroren in die friteuse geben
da hat der donau auf reserve und sind
die schön luftig und braun city von
früher von meiner kindheit aber bei der
amerikaner im depot in der kantine
dann gab es ja auch nur mikrowelle
damals quartal die warm gemacht auch
klar sein kindheits gefühle beim ging
also fertig mache ich zum zucker und
überholung ja sowieso noch 21 15 jahren
locken und ich zeige euch jetzt noch die
version mit zitronen puderzucker von
sowie homer simpson für den zitronen
guss verwende ich puderzucker wasser ein
bisschen zitronensaft ich hab' ich
lebensmittel verpasste vanille extrakt
und zum dekorieren natürlich auch zucker
streuseln
das nehme ich ja auch einfach einen
gesunden zitronensaft und je nachdem ob
jetzt gerne säuerlicher mögt oder nicht
so nimmt jetzt ein bisschen mehr oder
weniger und mich dann eben einfach mit
dem wasser ausgleichen und der coaster
so einfach schön dickflüssig werden
die witze noch vanille rhein gibt einen
tollen geschmack
ihr könntet auch einen gruß mit zimt
machen aber das war so brown
deswegen weiß ich das jetzt hier weg
lebensmittel verpasste und verrührt
so ist der kurs mal ein bisschen zu
flüssig also ein klein wenig puderzucker
und schreibe sich aber exakt gemessen
auf dem blog
wichtig ist natürlich auch das donuts
abgekühlt sind also wenn die zu heißen
dann läuft euch die glasur runter dann
oft auch die schokolade runter deswegen
die donuts schnell abkühlen lassen
danach dekorieren
wenn jetzt auch einfach eintauchen
bisschen abtropfen lassen und dann
dicker werden
herzlich willkommen zur sallys platz
heute im angebot
die schotthocker donuts und zimt donuts
und jetzt können die gäste kommen und
kostenlos ihren donath abholen ok der
leser erfährt also ich finde sie noch
cool aus oder können wir fast einen
donut laden eröffnen soll
jetzt müsste aber auch er alle ehrlich
sein wir alle ehrlich sein mir schmeckt
man sagt auch andrea ist normalerweise
gar keine dort kommt er kommt ihr auch
als ein paar von den rosa sind von
gestern abend wegen den fotos falls die
trockenheit liegt es nicht an mir
schoko hat die mit zimt sind auch
grotjahn ihm gleich ich hatte ja schon
einen jetzt sind also ich finde die von
dunkin donuts war nicht besser war
da fand ich dir bei dunkin donuts
trocken
ja und wenn ihr wollt können wir mal
welche mit füllung machen wir sind sie
die kommen nicht erst mitgefahren weg
und wie gesagt mit dem eintritt klappt
wunderbar einfach schön aufgehen lassen
wo es auf geklingelt wir kriegen noch
gäste
macht jemand kurz die tür auch einfriert
tipp hat auch geklappt das heißt ihr
könnt sie auch wunderbar einfrieren und
dann bei bedarf einfach frittieren und
das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auch
celtics - bob de jong aus palo dass ich
denke mal wer soll das alles essen und
dann klingelt sondern kommt man aber
hier sehe übrigens diese fertigen
belchen
das ist nämlich auch richtig cool mit
dem zucker ok oh warte ist die post hier
arbeiten donath haben können
ich mag es noch
ja ja aber das ist die kalorien
verbrennen
also macht 160 macht's gut macht's
besser und besucht uns in unserem tun
abladen in waghäusel der murat macht
jetzt doch jetzt selbst diese auch
hinten
[Musik]